it was on the floor of the House of
Representatives where our next guests
went to the floor and called for the
impeachment of President Trump here's a
bit of that statement I rise today with
a sense of responsibility and duty to
the people who have elected me a sense
of duty to this country a sense of duty
to the Constitution of the United States
of America I rise today mr. speaker to
call for the impeachment of the
President of the United States of
America for obstruction of justice
our guest is representative Al Green
Democrat from Texas and serves the city
of Houston good morning good morning sir
what led you to believe that this was
the right thing to do well first if I
may let me just tell you this I think
it's important this is not something
that I wanted to do it's something that
I feel compelled to do and I feel that I
must do this because the president has
obstructed justice when the president
fired the FBI director who was
investigating him and then went on to
tweet what might be considered some
threats or some strong admonitions that
was obstruction of justice now there are
many other things that are occurring and
these things may be evidence to further
the finding of obstruction of justice
but the President did it and by the way
the president confessed on national TV
so there's no need to investigate to
determine what the president said he
confessed on national TV with mr. Lester
Holt and so when it comes to the
reaction from Democrats they heard that
the same things you said as far the
president said as far as what he said
about the mr. Comey and the like they've
said that maybe impeachment isn't the
time for yet and more investigation just
needed even before they make that
decision how do you square with that
well I don't square with Democrats
because this is not about Democrats it's
about the democracy
it's about government of the people by
the people for the people and I don't
concern myself with the opinions of
Republicans because it's not about the
Republicans it's about the Republic
and what Franklin said when he told us
that you have a republic if you can keep
it so this is about keeping that
Republic and I am a voice in the
wilderness I understand that I may stand
alone but I still stand because the
president has obstructed justice when it
comes to this idea of obstruction of
justice you laid out your case of the
Harvard lost professor Alex Love whiting
had this to say about obstruction of
justice he said this he said it's more
difficult more difficult issue we proved
that mr. Trump's intent a corrupt intent
requires proof that mr. Trump acted with
an improper purpose and intent to
obstruct the investigation as opposed to
more benign lawful intent intent can be
proven by both direct evidence and by
circumstantial evidence to determine
intent prosecutors will look at the
available evidence concerning the acts
themselves but also mr. Trump's
statements and conduct before and after
the acts so you're saying with that in
mind what the president said to your
mind is obstruction of justice yes sir
and I think it's also important to do
this to separate the collusion from the
obstruction of justice because the
collusion does require a lot of
investigation and that should go on and
I hope that it will come to fruition in
an appropriate way
but the obstruction of justice has to do
with the president's own words we need
not look beyond what he has said I
indicated he confessed when he said that
he was doing it because of the
investigation that's a pretty
significant thing for a president to say
and then to go on and tweet out some
language that might be intimidating was
in furtherance of this act so it's
pretty clear that he did it now for
those who are looking for a definition
of obstruction of justice they might go
to 18 USC 1501 through 1507 and you will
find a proper definition that will take
in consideration the acts of the
president such that they can come to
their own conclusions
our guest is with us to talk about his
effort and what he said and the reaction
he's getting from that if you want to
ask him questions 202 seven four eighty
eight thousand four Democrats 202 seven
point eight thousand one for Republicans
202 seven for eighty eight thousand two
for independents and you can tweet us at
c-span WJ what has been the reaction and
particularly it was on your Facebook
page that you posted
statements made by your constituents can
you paraphrase what went on well are you
talking about the ugly phone call
correct yes I don't know that they were
my constituents that's why I had to ask
persons have made threats they have said
some very ugly things and it's my
opinion that you cannot hide hate you
have to expose it because there are good
many people who candidly sir do not
believe that the level of ugliness
exists that I have to cope with and that
persons of color have to cope with
immigrants have to cope with LGBTQ that
have to cope with so we have to expose
it so that people can see that there is
a reality that some people don't
experience but that others have to live
with so this is why we expose it and
what was said was in essence we will
murder you we will murder you Lynch you
is what was said but lynching is murder
give you a trial before we hang you and
Lynch you these are the kinds of vile
statements that we have to live with
doesn't matter if you're the head of a
seat you're a CEO of a major corporation
or if you're one of 435 members of
Congress people somehow believe that
they can intimidate you with the threat
of lynching we need to let people know
we also have to do this we have to
protect people in these congressional
offices there are young people working
there young staffers some of the people
are still in high school they're interns
and they shouldn't have to tolerate some
of the ugliness that we have to endure
but we signed up for the job and we're
going to do the job we will not be
turned around because of intimidation
this will in no way of thought our
efforts to move forward we will move
forward and as a matter of fact I am
currently crafting drafting if you will
articles of impeachment every member of
Congress has the right to file a
privileged resolution for impeachment
and it has to be heard within two
legislative days I'm a member of
Congress I'm crafting it but I'm not
doing that long
I have constitutional scholars who will
be working with me and at some point
we'll wait to see what others will do
and if no one else does the president
has committed an impeachable Act and I
will take it upon myself to move forward
with this that is what I have said that
is what I will do when do you expect to
do that I don't have an acid test for
the introduction of the resolution what
I have said is I'd like to see the
country weigh in on this the people
should weigh in this is a participatory
democracy people have to participate not
only on Election Day but on other
occasions when democracy is at risk so
this is a time for people to participate
we had an impeachment town-hall meeting
in my district I think people should do
this weigh in
let your representatives know where you
stand on this issue when the will of the
people is properly expressed the will of
Congress will change about 48% of the
American people think that the president
should be impeached currently there is a
strong sound solid plurality for
impeachment our guest representative Al
Green Democrat from Texas serves the 9th
district including the city of Houston
we have phone calls lined up for you sir
thank you our first one is from sherry
and sherry is an Oklahoma City on our
line for Democrats Jerry you're on with
our guest good morning good morning
I listen to the senator from Florida
this morning and he was making a and
Senate called a statement about the
importance of the leaks and and he
wanted the people who were leaking out
information about what's wrong no house
should go directly to the investor
investing investigating agencies but I
am concerned about if that happens if
President Trump is allowed to continue
to circumvent law by going in and and
calling on and these investigating
entities to quash the investigation if
if if it's going to be lost because he's
being able to be given
so much leeway in killing the law which
is really very frightening because once
we lose the law that protects us then
the country cannot sustain we will not
be able to sustain this democracy okay
Sharon we'll let our guests respond yes
the lady makes an important point we
live in a country where it is believed
that no person is beneath the law that
the law will protect people but we also
believe that no person should be above
the law that means that even the
President of the United States if he
commits obstruction of justice
he's got to come before the bar of
justice which is the US House of
Representatives
impeachment does not mean that the
president will be removed from office
impeachment simply means that he will be
charged the Senate has the trial the
house brings the charges if he is tried
in the Senate all of these issues about
who said what can be resolved because
the Senate will have subpoena power and
even the President himself can be
required to give testimony this is the
process that article 2 section 4 of the
Constitution allows us to engage in when
we have facts that constitute
obstruction of justice independent line
Jason from Alabama yes my question is if
President Trump actually did something
wrong you know where's the proof in it
you know I could understand if y'all
actually had proof now if he concluded
with Russians
I could see y'all doing impeachment or
something but you know as far as him
just running this mouth off
you know he's not a politician he's a
common folk businessman he's used to
just running his mouth off I like you
know Schumer and other people who are
running a mouth on slandering people
with no proof now they should be against
the law you know like I'm not a Democrat
or Republican I don't care either which
way but to have someone slander someone
else's name with no proof whatsoever I'm
hearing it on the news all the time and
I see Democrats
slandering like crazy and they showed no
proof okay call her Thanks
this is a very good point that you have
made sir it affords me the opportunity
to explain that the president's oral
representations coupled with his overt
manifestations of what would constitute
the proof necessary the president
doesn't just run off his mouth he not
only says that he will he fired the
director
but he said he fired him because of the
investigation now the investigation and
the collusion that's a separate issue to
be investigated separately but the
obstruction of justice occurred when the
president acted is not just any talk sir
he did act he did fire the director of
the FBI he did do so because the
director was investigating him and he
went on to intimidate with a tweet about
the recordings that may or may not exist
that constitutes obstruction of justice
now there'll be some other things that
will be called hard to attention the
memo from mr. Comey
that's secondary evidence and then the
latest attempts to encourage people to
do something that was inappropriate that
might be tertiary evidence and then you
might have a number of other things that
have occurred that would be quaternary
evidence but the primary evidence
occurred when the president fired the
director of the FBI who was
investigating him Republican line from
Maryland
Bonnie go ahead yes a good morning and
yes I was a die-hard Republican dull in
this anyway my point is why spend all of
this money when he can't be prosecuted
and to me the thing that proves to me
that he is doing that all for him you
had the Kushner's in China selling
citizenship to the highest bidder for
their hotel in New Jersey you have his
daughter on every trip with a while east
touken and on diverting everybody's
attention she's making deals with every
country like in Saudi Arabia he just
went there he made deals with them that
has something to do with his close ties
and it's all he doesn't care about the
people all he's in it for is the money
they need to take and follow the money
well I thank you ma'am
impeachment is the means by which the
president can be brought before the bar
of justice you use the term prosecuted
the president would be impeached first
and then he would be tried in the Senate
this is a proper process as a matter of
fact ma'am
it is the way a president is called to
justice because a president's not going
to be indicted and taken into a court of
law it has never happened my suspicion
is that it won't a president is first
impeached and then after impeachment
tried and then after tried extricated
from his office and after extrication
then that can be a follow up with
reference to some sort of criminal
prosecution how many Democrats have come
to you since where your statement last
week and said we support you in this I
would prefer not to talk about the the
kindness of my colleagues I have not
asked one person to support my endeavor
I have said this is a matter of
conscience and when the resolution is
presented people will have an
opportunity to vote on it I cannot
assure anybody that there will be any
number of people voting for it but I can
say this there will be at least one vote
for impeachment and I will stand alone
and I will stand with history I know
that this is clearly a case of
obstruction of justice and I will stand
on the law and the facts I represent
about green with us from Wisconsin
Democrats line Martin go ahead
good morning and thank you for your
service congressman thank you sir I am a
recently retired tradesman a white male
and a longtime lifetime supporter of all
things Democrat and I will just say
you're not representing me as a Democrat
it's quite embarrassing you're throwing
out impeachment and then you know the
LGBT people of color what happened to
supporting the white middle class you
seem to be absorbed in this identity
politics thing in this whole impeachment
is just part of that well thank you for
the opportunity to respond sir and I
assure you I have no intention ality
with reference to insulting you or the
white middle class I'm an integrationist
I believe that every person ought to
succeed on his merits or fail on his or
her demerits I believe that this is a
country that is diverse and that
diversity ought to be celebrated I
believe that that diversity crosses all
lines especially the color line I
believe we ought to have an inclusive
society I believe that we ought to stand
for liberty and justice for all
I believe that in this country and no
one is above the law which is why I do
what I do it has nothing to do with race
it has nothing to do with Democrats is
about democracy it has nothing to do
with Republicans it's about the Republic
it has everything to do with the
president not being above the law and
being brought before the bar of justice
so if I have offended you I sincerely
don't want you to be offended and would
extend an apology to you but this must
continue I'm sorry I really am but it
must continue that columnist Steve
Chapman who writes for several
newspapers said this about this topic of
impeachment he said forcing a president
from office is among the gravest tasks
members of Congress can undertake he
goes on to say to attempt it with so
many questions yet unanswered would look
like partisan revenge not just against
Trump but against the people who voted
for him
the law doesn't grant an exception
because of the appearances that may be
in place
I regret that people would take this
position that there are some appearance
of impropriety by following the
Constitution but I do say this I'm
concerned about how it looks which is
why I consistently say it's not about
Democrats or Republicans but as one of
435 members of the House we are split
between Republicans and Democrats if an
impeachment resolution is brought by a
Republican the same statement can be
made ifs brought by a Democrat the same
statement can be made so I don't know
how you escape these ostensible
representations I only know this the
Constitution does not make an exception
for these kinds of appearances it says
that if you commit obstruction of
justice article two section four not
those exact words talking about high
crimes and misdemeanors but if you
commit obstruction of justice which is a
high crime or misdemeanor then you can
be brought before the house it is one of
the most solemn responsibilities that we
have as members of Congress this is why
I don't do it lightly this is why I'm
not sought to ask other members to join
this what I believe to be an honorable
effort I let them make their own
decisions and at some point we will vote
now we can vote based upon something
that the Judiciary Committee brings
before the house or we can vote based
upon something that another member
brings before the house or we can vote
based upon what I and I don't like using
personal pronouns but what I will bring
before the house my mother taught me to
say we most of the time and I try but in
this case I am the voice in the
wilderness and I will do it I have no
fear there is no fear and because it's
not about the things that people like to
use as sometimes what I would call
sophisticated sophistry it's not about
that it really is it from our
independent line from Maryland Robert go
ahead yes good morning gentlemen are you
doing better than I deserve sir I have
the gift of life I can only appreciate
as
right the fact that I've been blessed
with it thank you so much yes
congressman look I'm a Vietnam veteran
and a lot of friends of mine died to
preserve principles of this country st.
Paul says in Romans the first chapter of
the Roman Empire proclaiming themselves
to be wise they became fools and God
gave them over to a reprobate mind
reprobate defined by the dictionary
means unprincipled doomed for damnation
what I see happening to my great
democracy greed greed is the instigator
for the destruction here and until our
politicians take control back of our
government away from these corporate
vultures and people like mr. Trump we
will be just like the Roman Empire
doomed for destruction thanks caller let
me just say to the caller I would invite
you to peruse a poem written by J
Patrick Kinney it's now the cold within
the cold within if you have time later
on today you might catch the floor of
the House of Representatives I plan to
address the cold within it speaks to
many of the circumstances that we will
have to cope with it speaks to cupidity
not stupidity cupidity religiosity
extreme religious joste t it speaks to
the things that are causing many of the
circumstances that we have to cope with
so I invite you to tune in c-span will
cover the House floor and sometime after
10 o'clock today I plan to have a
5-minute statement do you plan to follow
up then on this idea of impeachment
which you brought up today oh I
absolutely planned to but I will share
with you that today I I have to thank
people for the many kind things that
they've said and done given some of the
ugly things that have been said
and done so I will thank people who have
approached me many of them very
conservative who do not believe in
impeachment but they also don't believe
in this notion of threatening people
with lynching many of them are liberal
but I want to thank people for what
they've done little about impeachment a
lot about circumstances in the world
especially in lieu of what happened in
Britain yes
represent of Al Green a democrat from
texas serves houston in the 9th district
thank you for coming on it was my honor
to be with you sir
thank you